uh really excited to have dr nishan
gupta here with us assistant uh
professor from iit delhi to talk about
two many ways to die from poverty 19
results from the world's largest cohort
of lungs so
uh dr ishan gupta works for the
functional genomic group at iit delhi
and develops and deploy
bench to code noble omix technology to
measure biological phenomena with high
resolution single cell high precision
isoforms and high throughput
technologies so using this technology he
wants to understand the nature of
biologically complex diseases so
with that
i would like to invite
dr professor ishaan gupta so over to you
sir
um yeah hi can everybody hear me hello
yes yes we can you
hi is my screen visible
yes
you can see my slides
yes
okay
all right um thanks to the organizers
for um
hosting this talk i think there is some
issue with my computer so i'm gonna
basically be changing like this i hope
it's this is fine
with everybody
yeah
uh yeah does this work
yeah because i at this point of time
it's i'm on linux right now and it's
yeah
so can you do a full screen or
this will be the screen size yeah this
is the screen size unfortunately yeah
that's fine it's visible i think it's
it's kind of visible for the audience
and they can also like please let us
know in the chat if if you guys can see
the presentation
please let us know if if there is an
issue
it's visible so yeah um it's visible so
so you can go ahead professor yeah so
thank you thank you for having me um
so today we are going to talk about uh
i'm going to talk about some of the
results in my lab
where we have looked at uh
over 19 patients
from india and we have looked at their
uh bio like lung biopsies
and autopsies actually autopsies after
the patients are
passing away from the disease
and
typically there are three messages that
i
we have that i can give immediately is
that it's very important to actually
do such studies on indian patients on
indian cohorts
and not only rely on the results that
have been published from cohorts from
outside india because the genetics
and how
the patients the ex the environment that
is the patients are exposed to is very
different
which leads to very different kinds of
results
so that's the first thing first take
home message the second take home
message that i can give which is from
the title itself we find that there are
two very distinct ways in which
patients
would be responding to the disease and
therefore
are succumbing to the disease
and and the third thing is uh there is a
big
underappreciated
role
of
the resident lung microbiome or the
microbes that are residing in your lung
that could also play an important role
in kovid as i will try to motivate this
talk today so the most of the work that
i'm going to be presenting here was done
in collaboration with dr tibali jain at
ames
and was led by three students in my lab
anshul um on the left
so this is a paper that was recently
published um
in
the the journal dmm
disease mechanism disease models and
mechanism about
two months back
all right
so kovit 19 in india there have been
about uh five black people are dead so
five blacks would approximately be 500
000
dead but there is no molecular data from
india
so although we are a country with uh
one of the highest disease burdens of
the top three disease burdens
uh
and
a lot of like half a million people have
died because of this disease
there is
i mean very few data is there for
exactly looking at the
the patient types or patients of
isotypes looking at the molecular
biology of the patient there's a lot of
clinical data epidemiological data
but very little data from exactly how
the patients
look like under the microscope or
at the molecular level
so this is what we are setting to do
this is what we had essentially uh
doing so we are essentially took 10
patients uh
as controls and 32 patients who had
covered uh
19 also patients who had died of the
disease and we took uh core samples from
those
of course samples from these autopsies
um very fast so this is with a technique
called uh mits this massively invasive
tissue some massively uh
invasive
i don't think it's invasive uh this is
that you have an injection which gets in
like you put an injection onto the
lung samples or the tissue that you want
to sample
and um you can quickly uh minimally
sorry it's minimally invasive tissue
sampling you can quickly get a tissue
sample so the idea was that we sequenced
these samples
and did the rna sequencing we did the
quality control we aligned these samples
to the human genome
we found a differential transcriptome
analysis
for these
samples so basically figuring out the
differences between the covet samples
and the normal samples and
besides the data from the human genome
we also had data
from the microbiome that was resident in
the lung and that's what i'm going to
talk about
so one
major
result from our study
was that when we take a look at
the
gene expression level of the patients
we find
two kinds of patients so just to show
you the figure in this figure you see
that there are each dot is a patient
and the normal patients can be seen
in the color red and covet patients can
be seen in the color the steel blue
right and what you see is that when we
are plotting the gene expression
of these patients in higher dimensions
uh specifically capturing uh
the first two principle components uh
basically
characterizing how the how these
patients could be different at the level
of gene expression we find
that the patients are segregated into
two parts right so on the left side in
the left in the right side of the
of the graph on the left you have sets
of patients um covet patients and normal
patients clustering together and on the
right side you have only the covert
patients clustering together
so
this suggests that there is a group of
subgroup of poet patients so this is
approximately eight covet patients
um
who are actually
very similar to normal patients at the
level of gene expression
and on the other hand there's the
majority of the covariate patients about
three-fourths of these covariate
patients
look very very distinct from uh normal
patients
so
what could be the reason for this
uh is something that we try to figure
out in uh in this paper
so we had some
clinical annotation for these patients
like whether they had some
cardiovascular complications whether
they had diabetes they had liver
liver complications or other
comorbidities
and we did not find any signature so
basically these comorbidities could not
be the reason why the patients were
separated so here we have colored
uh a no is colored in red and a yes is
colored in in this blue color
right so what we find is that it's you
cannot clearly see that okay one of the
comorbidities like diabetes
is more enriched in the patients which
are
similar to the normal patients
versus patients which are extremely
distinct
although we do know that patients with
cardiovascular complications and
diabetes from our own work we have shown
in indian patients that
patients who have diabetes are more
susceptible to covert 19 but that's at
the clinical outcome level but at least
at the molecular level of how their
lungs are looking uh the gene expression
of their lungs are looking that's not
the case
so then what do we do we essentially go
ahead and assume
uh that these
two groups of patients are distinct and
then we compare each of these groups
with the normal sets of patients so
normal sets of patients here would be
these patients in red so what we do is
we do a comparison of differential gene
expression between this group which is
similar to normal which we call g1
and this other group which is very
distinct from normal that we call g2
when we do this
we find
as expected lots of genes that are
different between these two groups of
patients
specifically there are about 1000 genes
in total that are different between
these two groups some of them are going
up some of them are going down
and if you can see on this plot on the
right this is a typical heat map
on the first row
uh each column is a patient the first
row gives you the color of the type of
the patient so a light pink color means
this belongs to the g2 group
or the group that was most distinct and
on the right side top you have the dark
maroon color
which would be patients which are in the
g1 group and you have this blue color
which patients who are normal right
so if you look at the first uh if you
look at the first row set
first rows each row here is a gene you
see that there are certain genes which
are only expressed highly
in your
normal patients and they are not
expressed in either g1 group of patients
or geoproper patients
similarly if you go down
you have certain genes which are only
expressed in the g2 group of patients
mildly expressed in the g1 patients and
not expressed at all in the normal
patients
and then you have another set of sets of
genes which are expressed highly
in both g1 and g2 patients but are
practically absent in
the normal patients
so in order to understand what's going
on what separates these groups of
patients and what unifies these groups
of patients we can actually take these
lists of genes that we obtain after such
a differential expression analysis and
try to understand what are the common
pathways
that these genes belong to
all right so when we do this uh when we
are basically
separating these genes uh the
differential gene expressions are
treating it separately as expected for
g1 patients we have a much less number
of genes as opposed to g2 patients
and what we find when we do pathway
analysis is you have pathways such as
fibronectin beta chain c mu serum
amyloid apolipoproteins are upregulated
these pathways and
genes which are relating to say
scrna or
fab p4 they are downregulated here and
similarly in the case of g2
some interleukins
some angiotensin
enzyme by vitronectin
these enzymes are sort of upregulated
and a lot of snow rnas
or specific genes are not regulated
right there's a very little overlap
between these two patients just to
confirm what we saw in the pca plot
but in order to go deeper we now try to
look at which pathways are enriched for
these genes so specifically i'm showing
you here
the pathway enrichment analysis for
genes that are upregulated in g1
patients versus n patients and what you
see is that lipid metabolism
is upregulated
coagulation could be slightly
downregulated and there is upregulation
of sorry coagulation would be slightly
uh downregulated as negative cooperation
and uh neutrophil mediated immunity is
slightly down regulated and this is
something that was confirmed in other
papers by other papers and smaller
studies by targeted analysis and the
papers are mentioned here
when we look for g2 patients
specifically
one pathway which stands out is
complement activation
pathways in xenobiotic metabolism and
peroxisomal protein transport and this
was also supported by some of the
publications that came out
early last year
now this essentially means that the
disease that is being experienced by g1
patients and the disease that is
experienced by g2 patients
may look very differently molecularly
so what could be the reason uh everybody
would have heard of ac2 receptor and
tmpr vs2 protease
playing a role in search of two so we
try to figure out if the expression of
these two uh
genes could be uh
sort of indicative of what's going on
but uh for ace two definitely we did not
see any major changes in gene expression
and for dmpr ss2 as well uh there were
certain changes but when we correct for
multiple testing these changes do not
hold us that significantly
there are other proteins um which can
substitute for tmprs2 which is a
protease which helps the processing of
the spike protein uh when we tested
these uh these were also not really
convincing and
cannot distinguish between why
these two patients are experiencing the
disease differently
so the next thing that we did was we
tried to enrich for specific gene sets
uh that were known to be implicated uh
in uh in covet 19 basically some
pathways that are known to be sort of
uh
playing a role in the disease uh some of
the pathways uh you can see here this
was done by a tool called gsba which is
basically gene variation analysis um so
as you can see again we have similar
heat map plot but instead of plotting
genes
as in rows we are now plotting a score
for a pathway in in each rows
so if the pathway is up regulated you
would see a more green color if the
pathway is downregulated you'll see a
more purple color
and you can see there are pathways like
unfolded protein response which is known
to play a role in viral infections you
see that this pathway is highly up
regulated in the g2 centers of patients
so the g2 patients are all these
patients in green
your normal patients are in blue here
and the g1 patients are in red
so you see in g2 patients typically you
have high unfolded protein response
there is high oxidative phosphorylation
fatty acid beta oxidation is also high
and all kinds of complicated complement
systems classical alternative leptin
induced are all high
while in the case of both normal
patients
and g1 patients these pathways are not
high
right
similarly there are certain pathways
which are high
in the normal patients and in the g1
patients such as these il1 cytokines
which seem to be
low in the case of
our g2 patients the other other patients
apply
so what this kind of analysis
essentially tells us that there are
certain mechanisms or certain pathways
that are upregulated in both kinds of
patients so interleukin receptor
interferon response jack stat signaling
is is up regulated
in in both these patient types
but if you specifically look at g1
chemokine ligand signaling uh is
specifically such as the cytokines is
specifically upregulated in g1 patients
and here if we go down to what kind of
chemokine ligands specific genes that
could be found upregulated we find that
ccl19
which was shown to be a potential
biomarker for patient stratification
in the blood of covid19 patients
that was only upgraded in g1 while in
the case of g2 you had very high
presence of
all the complement system some chemokine
receptors
uh
dnf factors
tgf beta signaling so on and so forth
so with this analysis we can suggest
that why is it that the patients look so
different because the molecular biology
of the lungs
looks very different specifically in the
context of how chemokine signaling is
working
and in the context of
the complement system
in the g2 patients
and with ccl19 we actually have one way
uh one biomarker which should be uh and
which has been used for stratification
of patients to tell which patient could
be a g1 type or which patient could be a
g2 type
beyond this we also
can look at which specific
cell types in the lung could be affected
so their lung is composed of many
different kinds of cell types and what
we find is uh
we can have gene sets with respect to
each cell type and what we find is that
in the case of
your
uh copy 19 patients specific cell types
like proliferating basal cells or
alveolar epithelial type 2 cells they
seem to be disrupted and if we make a
sort of a plot for what kind of cells
are changing their proportions between
g2 and g1 patients
we specifically see that
on this
x equal to y line
your classical monocytes lipofibroblasts
dendritic cells they're all changing
similarly so either they're going down
in both g1 and g2 patients or they're
going up in one g1 and g2 patients but
two cell types specifically
proliferating basal cells and trem2
dendritic cells
are positively changing in g2 patients
but they are negatively changing in g1
patients which essentially means that
suggests that these cells could
potentially allow you to understand why
these patients are behaving differently
and maybe even design distinct
strategies to or
or drugs
to
treat these two patients differently
one thing that i started with in my talk
was to sort of motivate that such
studies have not been done in the indian
context and why they are important so
in this slide i would like to motivate
that so there was a study in 2020 by
nine hold at all where they
took 22 patients
the biopsies from 22 patients
fixed samples
we have fresh frozen samples
and what they found was they found that
there are 68 highly upregulated genes
and 30
uh significantly downregulated genes
because they were using actually a gene
panel instead of doing rna sequencing
and they found that specifically
interferon genes uh were
changing in this process
and what they did was they were able to
sub classify their patients into these
interferon stimulated gene height
category and low category
and they said that there are two kinds
of patients
the caucasian patients that they were
looking at there are two kinds of
patients in um
which have different kinds of
uh covet 19 manifesting
now when we do look at the same gene
sets in our patients
uh using gsps scoring
uh we don't find the results to be
replicating we don't
[Music]
don't find
our patient two subtypes the g1 and g2
subtypes to represent the same subtypes
that was found by an eyeball at all so
this essentially means that the kind of
the weight of the disease manifesting in
the indian patients is uh potentially
different from the way it is manifesting
in the asian patients or at least
the uh
we are using rna sequencing uh the
difference in technology could actually
be giving you different results so
uh
therefore this needs to be looked at at
least we are not able to reproduce the
results that they have shown
so the take home message for the talk so
far is that clinical covariates have
little impact on how the gene expression
of cobit 19 is segregating between the
two groups of patients
there are two potential kinds of these
patients
the patients recapitulate the molecular
aberrations or the changes in molecular
biology which has been reported so there
is unfolded protein response there is
il1 inflammation
there is change in the complement
pathway there is changes there is
changes in drug metabolism because most
of these patients were
under treatment
and there is down regulation of cross
pathways like olive action which was one
of the first signs of coping 19 where
smell was lost
and uh down regulation of dendritic
cells and t cells uh which are basically
going to respond to the disease
and we found certain uh specific things
in in in our coveted samples there was
enhanced lipofibroblasts and basal cells
and ciliary cells
and uh they were diminished genetic
cells specifically igf-21 positive
alveolar type 2 cells
and basophil mast cells and there were
certain cell types as i said which are
distinguishing between our two patient
types and we can
actually distinguish these patient types
based on certain chemokine markers as
well
the
second thing uh that we uh try to
actually look at is
uh the remaining twenty percent of the
reads which did not align to the human
genome when we were doing our analysis
and these remaining twenty percent of
the genes we found uh by aligning two
custom databases of bacteria viruses and
fungi they're actually coming from the
resident microbiome of the lungs
so
what we essentially found was if we
compare
covet samples
with normal samples
the microbiome diversity
was massively down regulated so not only
did these patients have
uh
infection from the covet virus but as a
result of uh infection from the covet
virus there was also
loss in the diversity of of the bacteria
that could be normally residing in the
lungs
and you can also look at this loss of
diversity in the context of a pca plot
where the abundance of each
genome that it was detected
for each microorganism that was detected
is plotted and you see that most of the
patients are on the right side
separating from all the normal patients
unlike at the level of gene expression
so there is definite dysbiosis
in these patients
and that is something that one has to
look at so one of the things that we
looked at in the case of dysbiosis was
that we were able to actually detect
complete genomes of the sarcophagus
virus itself from the sample so we were
able to actually get four
uh samples had high confidence detection
of sarcophagus and out of these four
samples in three samples we were able to
actually reconstruct the entire genome
sequence of the sarcovirus
and when we um
looked at which lineage these viruses
corresponded to so they were really into
the next clear lineage 20a or tango
lineage be 1.36 so this was the uh the
beta variant so this was corresponding
to the time of sampling
of of the variance so this sampling
happened in late uh 2020 early 2021
and it corresponded to the time where
the samples were taken so these samples
were deposited i'm sorry for the image
quality if i could have make it make it
bigger you would have seen it so these
samples were
submitted on a gsa i8 and we could see
that all of them were actually
sort of clustering with other samples
that was submitted from india and from
ames uh the hospital
and there were specific mutations that
we could see uh which would be
interesting for people who are actually
uh looking at how the virus is evolving
so as i said the variant that we found
uh were from this late 2020 early 2021
variant which is during the time of
sampling so that sort of is a sanity
check
for the fact that we were actually
capturing
coveted samples of that time that we
wanted to look at
now if we specifically look at how
the dysbiosis is happening in these
samples uh i'm instead of plotting all
the covariate samples together and i am
plotting the covet samples separately
the g1 and g2 samples separately from
the normal samples and you see that both
the g1 and g2 samples have dio
has dysbiosis with a reduced channel
diversity index
and although there is no differences at
the level of the g1 g2 groups themselves
that the
way that the dysbiosis has happened in
the two patients is quite similar so in
both the patients
the uh bacterial composition or the
microbial composition actually we are
also looking at viruses is uh is
similarly diminished
and now if we plot
the uh at the phylum level how these uh
in each individual samples how these are
looking at so for example each column
here is normal sample so the first
10 columns here are normal samples the
next
eight columns are g1 samples and the
next about 24 samples are the g2 samples
uh g2 patients and what you see is that
there is similar kind of trend there is
nothing which is like outstandingly
different between the g1 and g2 patients
at the level of phylum
but now if we specifically go and take a
look at the level of specific uh
species that we were detected
uh there are some trends
so if you look at this heat map again
each column
is a patient
the patients who are corresponding to
the blue column are normal patients
patients who are corresponding to the
red column are g1 patients patients that
are corresponding to the green column
are g2 patients
so now if we specifically look at these
rows which are marked as uh
g1 versus gn so these are these rows
represent strains
which are specifically found to be
present in a higher number in g1
patients
and much lower number in g2 patients so
one of these strains is staphylococcus
epi dermadi
dermatitis so this specifically is
opportunistic pathogen which is on our
skin
and this pathogen was found to be more
enriched
in g1 patients than g2 patients
similarly there is staphylococcus conier
that was found to be more enriched in g2
patients
they were present in slightly higher
number right and the g2 patients also
had
pathogens like aspergillus
or isa
and some viruses
similarly there was other
other sort of resident microbiome which
could possibly be protective
um such as
shown here so all these bacteria
micrococcus nutrients
ralestonia all of these are
the bacteria which are potentially uh
so no depleted in in the covet patients
so what this sort of suggests
is that there could be
specific species of bacteria which
can
colonize
the immunocompromised niche of of the
lungs
of the patients who have been suffering
for covet covered 19 and interestingly
what you'll find is that the code 19 was
only detected in like six patients so
the lungs had cleared out the infection
so basically the take home message for
this part of the talk is that this bios
is uh you see dysbiosis in almost all
the patients of cobit 19 and there is
definitely enhanced presence of
staphylococcus infections in both the
kinds of patients
and we were able to recover cov19 even
in these patients during close to their
uh
just before
they gave up
in 20 of the samples and we were able to
actually recover with high confidence in
four samples we were actually able to
recover the entire virus itself
so the outlook
that one could have
from such an analysis is that working on
a country-specific cohort like we have
done um revealed new subtypes so it's
important to actually go around and
whenever you are actually looking at
some molecular phenotyping of a disease
it should be done across the world
across different populations and
definitely major
large population groups of the world
should be represented like india which
is typically not
what we find is that there are specific
pathways which are changing between the
patients
and there are specific uh suggestions
that we have for stratification of the
patients uh based on these pathways or
based on the molecules that could be
found in the blood
uh that could act as a proxy for these
pathways such as ccl19
the fact that we have gene expression
changes can be used to also do some in
silico drug screening something that
i've not shown but if you're interested
you can go and take a look at the paper
and also we could find that these
changes are specifically happening in
certain cell types in the two different
patient types
which can be used for designing targeted
therapies
and then there is definitely a role of
the microbiome in the lungs of the cover
19 patients
that needs to be further investigated
and we don't
cannot rule out the possibility that the
reason why the patients are not
the patients had a tough time
or could be because of these infections
rather than the covenant because these
patients mostly had cleared away the
infection uh we were not detecting
kubernetes and actually majority eighty
percent of the patients
so i'll end my talk here and i'll be
happy to take questions
thank you
thank you so much dr shan for such an
interesting talk
and i have some questions for you uh we
want to understand is it the normal
patients which were taken on healthy
volunteers like normal patients
suffering from
disease if yes then water complications
will survive
yeah so this is a good question so we
took basically
uh autopsies of patients who were
suffering from lung cancer so typically
when you were taking autopsies for or
not obviously biopsies so you would take
some tissue which would be normal tissue
and some tissue which would be cancer
tissue so we were using the tissue that
was normal tissue from lung cancer
patients so these lungs were already
inflamed
so they should have had some information
signatures uh
so that that's those were the available
samples that we had
for ethical clearance
all right